the model context protocol has everyone
fired up including me because of the way
that it standardizes giving tools to llm
with it creating powerful AI agents that
can practically do anything on your
behalf has never been more accessible
however as powerful as it is it's pretty
limiting when you have to use
applications that natively support mCP
like claw desktop wind surf or cursor
the true power comes in building our own
AI agents you and I both know that but
how do we integrate mCP servers with our
own agents so we can use these tools for
ourselves and that my friend is the
million dooll question because then we
can build our own front ends and apps we
can integrate mCP servers with other
tools that we built for our agent we can
even pick and choose the different tools
that we pull from these servers you can
see that this is when really the
possibilities become truly Limitless and
you're in luck because integrating mCP
servers with your own AI agent is
exactly one going to show you how to do
in this video we're going to use pantic
AI as our AI agent framework but what
I'm going to show you how to do is going
to apply no matter your framework and
even if you don't want to use one at all
and the best part is it's actually
pretty simple and if you follow along
with this video and you take the
template available for you in GitHub
you're going to be able to do all this
for your own AI agents in less than a
half hour really exciting stuff so let's
dive right into it so if you're not
familiar with mCP I would highly
recommend checking out this video that
I'll link to above where I did a very
comprehensive overview but now what we
want to do is take all of these
beautiful mCP servers that give us tools
for all these different services and
just like we can very easily inject
these into an app like CLA desktop we
want to bring them into our own AI
agents and so if we want Brave web
search for our agent or we want our
agent to work with a GitHub or rag
through chroma all of these different
servers we can configure them for our
agent just like we can do with claw
desktop and I'll show you how to do all
of that and I even have an example of
this that I want to show you really
quick cuz this just shows that we can
build a custom front end for our agents
with mCP so I took the agent that we are
about to build together I turned it into
an API endpoint for the live agent
Studio platform that I've been working
on and so I can ask it something simple
like search the web to get the latest
news for mCP and this seems simple at a
surface level just like a lot of the
other agents that I built on my channel
but it's using the brave mCP server
under the hood and so I did not create
this function myself for it to search
the internet with brave and I've always
done that in the past and I have all
these other servers hooked in as well so
I can say what local files do I have and
I can use the local file mCP server and
I have sqlite as well and it's so easy
to extend the configuration to add in
any servers that you want that are from
this list and there a lot of other ones
that aren't on this list either and so
it's just that easy to add functionality
into your agents now that's why mCP
makes tools so accessible so if you're
curious how I figured out all of this I
just used two pieces of documentation so
here in the official mCP docs I went to
quick start for client developers this
shows you at a high level how to create
an mCP client with python and then a
more in-depth example that I referenced
even more is this one in their python
SDK GitHub repo and this shows you
exactly how to set up an mCP client so
you can configure your servers in the
same way that you would for something
like Claud desktop or winds surf with
that CLA config Json file and so I
followed all this to a just so that you
know that what I'm about to show you is
really following the best practices that
anthropic is laying out for mCP and so
with that let's dive right into the code
so here is the GitHub repository where I
give you everything you need to connect
your mCP servers to your custom AI agent
right now using pantic AI in this
example but I'll show you later how you
can make this work for any framework
that you want to use and at the root of
this repo which I'll have Linked In the
description by the way I have this
readme that walks you through everything
you need to get up and running yourself
and the best part is I have this quick
start at the top where in just four
steps you can take what I've built here
this custom mCP client that works with
your Frameworks and you can bring it
into your own project and so first you
just need to copy the mCP client.py
script this is the custom client that I
created so you can take this script and
bring it into your own project and then
the only dependencies here is pantic AI
or whatever framework you are using and
then the mCP python SDK itself so just
install these with tip and then we can
move on to setting up our configuration
and I did it on purpose where I made it
so that the way that you configure your
mCP servers is exactly the same way that
you would do it for another application
like CLA desktop so just making it as
simple and standardized as I possibly
can for you so I have this example in
the repo for what this config would look
like this should look very familiar to
you if you've used mCP before and the
way that you know how to set up each of
these individual servers is you just go
to the GitHub repo that lists all of
these servers you can click onto any one
of them and then in the instructions
like for the brave search mCP server for
example I can scroll down and then it
gives me the usage with claw desktop add
this to your config.js you can follow
the exact same instructions just copy
this config and bring it into your own
Json file here that is it and then the
very last step is to set this all up in
your python code so you import the
necessary things from mCP and pantic Ai
and then with this function right here
it is only four lines of code we create
an instance of our client we load the
servers based on the configuration file
and obviously set this to the right path
to your own mCP config.js and then we
get a list of tools by starting the
connection to each server with our
client and then when we create that
instance of our pantic AI agent and it's
going to look very similar for for other
Frameworks the way that we pass in our
tools is just this right here so all of
the tools that we got when we connected
to our servers and we listed all their
tools under the hood with this call
we're just passing that in for the list
of tools to our pedantic AI agent and
then in your main function wherever you
want to use this agent you just have to
fetch it with this line of code and that
is it so you now have an AI agent built
with pantic AI that has access to all of
the tools from our servers that we
defined in the Json it is that simple
and in this repo I also have examples
for how we can use this within an AI
agent and the first thing I want to show
you is what it looks like when we have a
pantic AI agent not set up with mCP and
then we'll contrast that with how simple
it is with it and so in this example we
get our environment variables to define
the model we want to use we set up our
dependencies for pantic AI just all
standard pantic AI stuff we Define our
agent and then for all the tools that we
want to give our agent we have to Define
individual python functions for all of
the capabilities that we want to give it
and so in this case we're just giving a
single tool to our agent for it to be
able to search the web with the brave
API and look at how much code this is
for just a single tool and if we really
wanted to make it something like our mCP
agent where it has dozens of tools from
all these different servers we'd be
creating dozens of different functions
and that gets very cumbersome you can
see how without mCP there is just so
much code that we have to create for all
of our agent capabilities and and so
contrast that with mCP take a look at
this this is the same implementation for
a pantic AI agent but this time we are
leveraging that function that I showed
you in the readme to hook into our mCP
servers with our custom client and then
use those tools for our agent instead of
having to Define individual functions
ourselves it's so much less code and we
have way more tools available to us and
that's the beauty of standardizing
things with mCP we don't have to create
the tools our elves I mean we still can
if we want but we can reuse what other
people have made for us and that's not
really possible without something like
mCP providing that standardization and
then the way that we interact with our
agent it's still the same way under the
hood I mean these functions in our our
main function here is pretty much the
same and so there's nothing crazy
magical or different going on here but
that's good because we still want to
work with our agents in the same way
just make the tooling easier to set up
and that's what mCP does for us and so
now I can go into my terminal and run
this basic mCP agent and you'll see that
at the beginning it'll load our mCP
servers like we see right here and now I
can ask it something like I have this
example here search the web to find the
newest local llms and just this is just
to prove to you really quick that it can
connect to those mCP servers under the
hood because all of the descriptions for
each of those tools are given as a part
of that prompt to our pantic AI agent
just like when we Define tools the old
way with our code so I'll just give it a
little bit and there we go yep gave us a
markdown search the web to find the
latest local llms so yeah super super
neat the sponsor of today's video is
Cosmic up an allinone place where you
get access to all the best llms under
one subscription and it's only5 for the
first month and so 03 mini Claude 3.7
Sonet Gemini 2.0 flash thinking you get
access to all of these and you don't
have to pay the more expensive separate
subscriptions and there are other apps
like Cosmic up but what makes it stand
out is that there are no rate limits for
over 30 of the best llms and it uses the
direct API for all the different
providers and so all that together I've
not seen before so over in their app
Cosmic up.me you'll be presented with
this interface that looks very familiar
to us and that's good because at a core
we want all the same functionality of
Claude and GPT but Cosmic up just
provides that and a lot more so I can
have a conversation with it like I
normally would in a chatbot I mean look
at how fast this is even for 03 mini and
then if I click on this drop down I can
see all the different models available
to me there's everything that I would
want and I could even do something like
start with a Reasoner llm and then
switch to something faster like GPT 40
mini in the middle of a conversation and
something else that they have that I
don't see a lot is you can use folders
to organize your different chats which
is super neat and then they have all the
core functionality that you would expect
like uploading files for your images and
PDFs you can use image generation with
mid journey in Dolly you can do web
search improve your prompts with an llm
chat with your voice it is the package
that has it all as far as platforms go
to quickly give you access to all the
best llms Cosmic up is definitely at the
top of the list and if you're not
convinced at this point you can try it
for free you won't have access to all of
the llms but you can use GPT 40 mini CLA
3.5 Hau and mistol unlimited for free
just to get a feel for the platform so
I'll have a link in the description to
Cosmic up definitely go ahead and check
them out and then this really basic
implementation and this non mCP version
I'm going to remove these from the repo
just to clean it up but I have a more
robust implementation that I'll leave in
the repo that actually streams the
output to the console as the agent is
producing the response token by token
and so if you want to run this full
example I have instructions for that in
the readme so if you go past the quick
start you can dive into what it looks
like to set up your environment
variables to actually have an llm hooked
into this agent so this is a full
example whereas the quick start is just
at a high level how you can bring this
into your own project so I hope that
makes sense and then the other thing I
want to show you how to do is build this
custom mCP client because when you take
this client script into your own project
you can change things up to make it work
for other Frameworks for example so I
want to show you how I built this so you
can know how to customize this to your
own needs because in the end this client
is just a starting point for you I want
you to take this and run with it and so
let's dive into building this from
scratch and there are some more
complicated parts to this that I just
learned by following the documentation
that I showed earlier from anthropic
things like handling our resources when
we crash our application or end it
manually we want to make sure that we
also tear down our mCP servers and so
you'll see some lower level code for
that but I'll call out the important
details that are really worth paying
attention to so the first thing we're
going to do is import all of our
libraries and configure basic logging
then we'll create our class that will
represent each of our individual mCP
servers and the first thing that we want
to do when we initialize a new server is
we want to give it the name and then
also our configuration so file system
would be our name and then the
configuration would be these lines for
example with our Command and arguments
and then we also have a session defined
this is where we store that connection
for the client to this specific server
and then again some lower level code for
the resource cleanup stuff and then we
have a function to initialize the server
connection where we're going to create
our Command again based on the type of
server if it's a python Docker or
JavaScript mCP server and then we'll
raise an error if there is no command
defined otherwise we'll Define our
parameters for the mCP server so we have
the command then we have the arguments
and then if it's something like the
brave server where we have an API key as
an environment variable we'll Define
those right here as well and so now that
we have the parameter set up just using
the studio server parameters object that
we import from mCP now we can actually
make that connection so a little bit of
lower level code to create that protocol
to connect to the server through the
client make that session and then
finally we can initialize it and so this
is a little bit more of the complicated
part to the code so don't worry if you
don't understand all this you can just
use this template that's why I'm saving
you a headache here getting this all
implemented for you but yeah the
important thing is at the end of this
function we now have this session that
we set right here for our client session
so we now have have that connection to
our server and then we handle any errors
as well and then we have our all
important function to take the tools
that we have for our mCP server and
convert them into the format that we
need for pantic AI and so it's very easy
to get these tools from an mCP server we
just take that session that we just
initialized with this function and we
call the list tools function it's that
easy we get a list of tools and then we
can use a helper function to convert
each one into the format that we need
for pantic AI which Speaking of that
that is going to be this function right
here so we take in an mCP tool and then
what we get out is a pantic tool and you
can create a similar function to do this
conversion for crew aai or Lang chain or
your own framework whatever you want to
do because all we do is I'll just kind
of throw these out all at once here is
we create a couple of functions that we
need to work with this tool and then we
Define an instance of the pantic tool
class and so we have this function to
actually execute the tool on once we
want to use it in our agent and then we
have the name we have the description of
the tool so the agent knows what the
tool is all about and then we have this
prepare function and so this is where we
get the Json schema for the function so
the agent knows the parameters like if
we're creating a local file it'll now
know that oh we need to give the file
path and the contents that we want to
put in this new file or for searching
the web we need to know the query that
we are using for the web search and so
all that is defined in the parameter
here that we just pass as that last
argument and that's it for this function
we now return an instance a converted
instance of the tool specifically for
pantic AI and that's how we get this
tools array in this other script that
has the format so you can just pass it
directly into our pantic AI agent
instantiation and then we have a cleanup
function that I'm not going to cover in
detail here this is how we tear down the
mCP server when our application is done
and now with that we can create our mCP
class and this is where we manage all of
our different server connections and so
in our initialization function we create
that list of mCP servers that's this
class that we just finished creating and
then we have our configuration the list
of all the tools that we pull from these
servers together and then another lower
level thing to manage our resources and
then in our function to load servers
this is where we pull in our
configurations so we open up this Json
file and then for each of the servers
that we have here we're going to get the
name which is like file system or Brave
search and then we also get the
configuration and so that's everything
within that Json object for one of these
servers like this is all the config for
brave this is all the config for the
file system and we just create an
instance of the mCP server for each of
those items in the Json and then to
actually start each of these servers
begin that connection for our client we
have this start function and so we're
just going to Loop through all the
servers that we pulled from the config
and initialize them it's very very
simple and then we can call that create
pantic AI tools function to get a list
of the tools from that server converted
into pantic AI so we'll get that we'll
build up this list of tools handle any
exceptions and then finally return these
tools and so when we call this start
function within our other script that's
this right here that's how we're getting
that list of pantic AI tools back and so
the hierarchy of this is we call client.
start and then within client. start
we're calling the create pantic AI tools
for each of the servers and so the
client manages all of the servers and
then at a higher level we manage the
client with just these few lines of code
right here and that's it and then we
have a couple of cleanup functions just
to handle the resources again not going
to go into this but that is everything
for our client and servers so now with
all that out of the way I can go into my
terminal and run the command python
pantic mCP agent dopy that's running
this script right here with those four
lines of code where we first instantiate
our client connect it to all of our mCP
servers and now those tools are
available indefinitely for our agent
right here in the terminal and so I can
even go into Docker desktop and see that
for my Docker servers we've got a
container running for each of them my
Brave git and SQL light and I can say
something like hi I can have a normal
conversation where it's not using any of
these mCP servers but then I can say
search the web for Elon musk's net worth
in March of 2025 and so it'll use the
brave mCP server and I could ask it to
do something with the file system or git
or sqlite it can dynamically use all
these different tools that we've now
injected into our agent from mCP and the
other thing I want to show you is if I
crash this program just doing control C
then I can go back to Docker desktop and
see that those servers were instantly
cleaned up so we're managing resources
nicely here which is something I've seen
not done well including the
implementation for n8n by the way just a
fun tip there they still have to figure
that out that's a really important thing
but yeah that's everything like we it
was that easy to set it up and now we
can go over to that list of servers in
GitHub and pull even more to put into
our config here we can extend the
functionality of our agent so easily
whereas before we had mCP we had to go
into our python code for our agent and
Define an individual python function for
every single functionality and
capability we wanted to give our agent
and with mCP it's just so much easier
now so the last thing that I want to
touch on here is right now this AI agent
is just a conversational agent hooked
into a few mCP servers it's nothing you
couldn't do with claw desktop but I hope
that you can use your imagination to see
that when you are creating the agent
yourself and making your own client the
possibilities are Limitless for example
you can actually integrate it in your
own app or front end now you can't do
that if you're stuck to claw desktop and
like I showed you earlier at the live
agent Studio you can go into this folder
and you can see exactly how I did that
where I created a fast API endpoint for
my mCP agent so that I can use it as an
API endpoint for my SAS or my portfolio
website or for my YouTube channel like
whatever it is I can hook that as an API
endpoint into any frontend or app that I
make and you just can't do that unless
you're building your own agent and then
another really neat example is right
here where I'm pulling all the tools for
my mCP server you can Implement custom
filtering so you're only pulling in some
tools from the server sometimes you
don't want to bloat your llm with a ton
of tools that you aren't going to use
but if you're using something like winds
surf or cursor or claw desktop whatever
like you're forced to use all of the
tools that that server gives you and
sometimes you don't want that and so
when you have that lower level control
like we have here there's just so much
more you can do for making it into your
own application or having more control
over the tools you use them and how you
invoke them you don't have that unless
you're doing a custom implementation so
I hope that really stands out to you why
this is so valuable so I hope this video
made it as easy as possible for you to
take all the power of mCP and bring it
into your own AI agents and let me know
in the comments if you have any
questions at all I would love to help
you plus I have a lot more content
coming in the near future for mCP
because I truly believe that the way
that it standardizes AI tools is
revolutionary stay tuned for that so if
you appreciated this content you're
looking forward to more things AI agents
and mCP I would really appreciate a like
and a subscribe and with that I will see
you in the next video